hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it but I don't wanna I don't
want to remember this movie is so awful
I wish it was lobotomized from my brain
if it moves the fight of my brain that
forgets what my penis was I still want
to apologize huh buck up this is tango
just I mean this is lucky McDonald's
playground after you smoked a pile of
horseshit it's stupid it's nonsensical
and it's annoying annoying annoying
before we take a look at this delightful
ass-raping let's take a look at a little
history and I do mean little because I
never actually read the comic book this
movie was based off of but to the comics
credit it looks pretty cool I think one
of the guys who developed the gorillas
ban worked on this comic and it shows
the artwork is really awesome the
character seems like fun and I really
like the setting of this sort of punk
apocalyptic future will be the word for
punk elliptic I don't know and I guess
it did well enough that Hollywood
finally came by to try and run and they
certainly did a bang-up job of that so
let's not wait any longer even though
I'm sure many of us want to let's take a
look at Tank Girl so I would tell you
the back story of this little opus but
he'll why don't I let Harley Quinn's
retarded sister Talia listen up because
I'm only telling you this once not
bedtime story lady so pay attention
wow I hate you already you see awhile
ago this humongous comic came crashing
into the earth BAM no celebrities no
cable TV no water it hasn't rained in 11
years
what's that nobody will get the Frank
Herbert's dune jokes alright I'll keep
them out and then they show us one of
the most poetic beautiful images ever to
be associated with the desert on film
since Lawrence of Arabia
my heart leaps every time this button
image pretty much sums up the feel of
the movie I mean look at her she looks
like she got a makeover by the
sandpeople so she goes roaming through
the desert looking for water to steal
witness exhibit boy super date stunts
aren't as funny as they used to be so
she takes off her mask to reveal herself
as Gwen Stefani actually this is Rebecca
played by Lori petti yeah you know the
whiny little sister from a league of
their own did you always want to see her
in a starring role that is holy pony
actually that's a drawing of it but okay
you've been stealing but we'll give you
that idea
take off your clothes do not imagine a
woman directing this movie a woman who
hopefully is an or knee as hell
a woman who openly hate to look into
making male body as much as I do
gross out come on being weird you oh
thank god that's dad will take more than
children to save you so yeah these two
are fucked up as we then cut to the
location of our main villain wah wah wah
wah
okay another drawing oh but what you
can't even show the real building you
gotta show a drawing of it what's the
point of having a building if you can't
have a building is the idea that just
was better than the comics of the night
again bother to show us so we see our
bad guy who runs all the water in the
world named Kesley played by malcolm
mcdowell who really needs the fire his
agent Adam was dust until God injected
him with life and do you know what was
in that injection spur Wotan well that's
now how I heard about the birds and the
bees to captain douche that final crack
of land will be ours
this crack of land huh now look what's
happened
and the channels enriched I'm Sean and
Sarang no oh gosh do I make myself clear
yes yes sir good now get me more things
to smash so he scares captain ladouche
or whatever the name is and steals all
the water from his body
aqua is big ball lovely why is the point
did you just run out of footage so you
threw the storyboards in there
Rebecca Rebecca Rebecca Rebecca thank
you this is the producer of the movie
the scene you just saw serve no purpose
and probably should have been edited out
the final product our apologies but
Rebecca is approached by one of
McDonald's soldiers trying to stop their
illegal water stealing but Rebecca tries
to flirt her way out
da Sam not quite plumb in my face my one
weakness not something ah shit I like
how he doesn't even yell like he's
thinking to himself I'm an extra in
tango it's not like I really have to try
I won't be putting it on my resume
so they shoot up all the people inside
but for some reason keep Rebecca alive
there's your water yeah well Roger fit
special effect you are clear to land
so she winds up with McDowell as he
tries to offer her a chance to work with
abandon o ye who enter here
I think they wrote that out of tickets
for this movie I'm offering you the
chance of a lifetime the honor of
working for me
not yet you're aware me yo where be so
they make her a slave in his company and
she tries to fight back with her witty
comebacks hey I don't want to miss big
one hahaha Baywatch it's funny because
it existed meanwhile a woman named jet
played surprisingly by Naomi Watts is
trying to fight off a guard who won't
stop hitting kicking on my girlfriend
okay this movie just went up a notch
alright please something another notch
Oh Oh God that's groans I'd never want
see to women kiss ah okay what is the
idea behind having the comic-book
drawings in the movie seriously it's
like a comic book coming to life without
it actually coming to life so Rebecca
sneaks around the place looking for
appropriately enough attend why are they
playing shaft I mean I've been trying to
pants off that bed somehow not shaft
because that's so obviously shaft
you can even put the lyrics to it listen
who's this good at you completely tanks
like it's a deep character is bland and
no one understands her even the audience
but sadly the tank doesn't work so
Rebecca thinks she knows the woman who
can get it right miss me
I did not what are you doing oh I was
just thinking about leaving this place
what are you reckon we got New York see
cats cats Baywatch oh man I these
references we never age you just gotta
think about it like the first time he
got laid
he just got a go daddy are you sure this
is right Wow
that's offensive and unfunny it's like a
female jiff done it thanks God lock her
away for good this time
huh I never thought I'd be able to use
this line in a way to make sense but I
was frozen today hey never gets old
I'm going to ask you just one more time
where's my career do you want to work
for water power I get to work you out
feel like yours so the coin to user to
set off these booby traps to try and get
to the lair of these water fated simply
known as the rippers but wind you know
it the rivers show up in their
half-assed predator costumes and kill
all the guards leaving Rebecca and Velma
from scooby-doo here alive you better go
before they come back first you take a
tank
oh no she said during Mulholland Drive
oh I guess when the promo for the
Saturday morning cartoon now what did
Disney take over any why is this why
does this someone look like Andy Warhol
spit up okay whatever we see McDowell go
through some sort of Vanilla Sky
operation to make up for what the
rippers did to it won't bite is young
all the king's horses and all the king's
man don't want the bonafide do we know
they had the technology I have oh it's
the same voice bots are using tickle me
Amy
Amy's voice box is copyright protected I
will sue their asses and fuck them up
hard and you well know my name is the
Lord when I lay my vengeance upon thee
all right I can't stop playing with you
so they drop by a bordello called liquid
silver where funny enough that little
girl named Sam happens to be
unfortunately she's called in to try and
please a pedophile
it isn't that just charming
you're gonna get fired we keep treating
the guests like that I found my mother
maybe personally but they want to teach
the owner of the place the crazy bad
draught like the crow here a lesson she
won't forget jinkies motherfucker ooh
what are they gonna do they're gonna
wrap her up a bit or destroy the place
and make her watch or Quinn the little
booboo at her as Saint Ned would a
mother giant death that's not very bad
punishment in the middle of welcome to
the bottom of the barrel people and
actually film with a horrible music
number no point no reason just
coordinate complete and total cornice
crust
ladies I really can't believe they're
insulting our intelligence as much this
is just painful
all right I hate this movie so much and
this scene in particular that I'm
willing to go so far as to show pictures
of starving children that we coulda
saved with the money used on this
picture
that really makes you think could be
glitz diving children movement so
because they decide to do their rape a
Broadway Sam gets kidnapped again go on
Rebecca good why Ripa's are you kidding
look we're gonna rescue Sam we're gonna
need an army they're an army yep oh we
have no time for your opinion we only
have time for craptastic musical numbers
they get children kidnap come on Lady
kpop so they try to find the rippers to
see if they can get health savings Sam
as they stumble upon them later oh my
god the wires of birch oh this is a bug
husband came over back yeah so it turns
out the rippers are giant kangaroo
sounds like something Willy Wonka would
create when he's completely drunk and
one of them if you can believe it is
actually played by rapper ice-t now go
despot imma kill him I said wake up in
fact how did he gain him to sign up in
this movie work exactly did he really
just think this was the role of a
lifetime for him
alright ice-t I know you got a lot of
projects in the works but just listen to
this movie role yeah okay you're a
kangaroo fuck yeah Dolan tale of
comforting T say aye aye shut up and go
phenol crumpets and tea well that's
something I never thought I'd hear ice-t
say we're gonna take them outside right
now waste them
so they waste a lot of time with these
kangaroo jack shits as they finally
agree that they'll help them save Sam if
they can get some weapons to help them
out
sir one minute time my steps are lethal
ice cream truck
oh she's roasting a hot dog it's funny
because people don't often roast hot
dogs during an action scene shit is
pretty wash you
so after pee-wee's big tank adventure we
move on to more important seats Mike and
I'm not kidding here wrapping marsupials
fuck it I'm just going to show you the
things you could be doing right now as
opposed to watching this movie
okay what what is up with the comic
shots I am sick of them they serve no
point no purpose why haven't in the
movie actually though I got I just
figured it up I bet you anything they
ran out of money they forgot to shoot
like a bajillion scenes so they just
threw a bunch of pictures and from the
comic hoping nobody could tell the
difference Frank what do you mean we're
out of money we still have 24 more
scenes to shoot what improvise ventures
I'm flying shit happening
Water and Power has mined all the way
from here to here we've got the stolen
flyer all we have to do is paint it back
the way it was and pale wait are you
sure we have enough comic pages for that
so they try to break into the villains
hideout by far taking it okay are you
even trying movie
yes this ridiculous jackass not that can
easily be checked out we'll definitely
get us in safely
so they put Sam in a pipe filling with
water as you might have noticed they're
not showing McDowell's things probably
because they're building up the surgery
that was done on it earlier it's getting
ridiculous though it's like he's turning
into dr. claw I look at you next time
dead girl next time so there might be
more fan kangaroo jizz break-in to kick
some tail in oh wait a minute you can
see the strength goddamn a movie you
know it's a $0.50 I bought you for the
dollar store I can do a weak voiceover
that loud gunfire so McDowell finally
shows his face to reveal it looks
exactly the same
well I used to disappointment by now so
I'm not really that bummed actually
turns out that McDowell's head is now a
hologram I knew it I knew the real
Malcolm adult when sign up for a movie
this stupid it was a hologram all along
my clock will go on juice read ahead
come on girl oh I'm so pretty uh yeah
isn't that little girl drowning right
now need a hand
come on girl oh I'm so pretty I'm gonna
hit you so hard no children will be born
bruise yeah up up up I'll just say I won
and the little girl live I'd rather hurt
die than live as your slave well I
didn't think she that should be safer as
a slave than having you as a mother
alright so quick wrap up she defeats
McDowell finally saves the girl and
kisses one of the kangaroos you and it
doesn't really end as much as just show
us more of those pointless Ren and
Stimpy cartoons happy happy joy joy
happy happy joy every day happy
but how Karis tanker was very
appropriately named as it appropriately
tagged at the box office the one showing
it it's horrible it's long it's annoying
it's just a painted sister from
beginning to end
fuck this movie fuck everything anything
at do it I'm a nostalgia critic if
you'll excuse me think I have some money
one donate to some starving kids I mean
god she's just a girl